so during the semester we have a few
recitation instructors they help with
the students during the recitation
section so during those sections your
the the instructor will solve a similar
problem like what is actually covered
during the same during the lecture and
that give the students another chance to
look at more example and to get for
media will get used to the calculation
which we carry how for the first time
during the the lecture so also the
recitation section and during the
recitation section the instructors help
the students they can actually ask more
questions during the recitation sections
including the questions they have the
pset or any additional questions they
they thought about after the lecture ok
so that they get some chance another
chance to clear some of the concept
which they don't really understand
during the during the lecture so we did
not record the recitation sections
during the fall semester in 2016 on the
other hand we included problem-solving
videos from Professor with Busha which
is similar to what we do during the
recitation sections from previous years
to to go with the lecture videos done
during the semester